[Musica]
Quanti di voi hanno in tasca in questo
momento uno smartphone che ha una
connessione a internet Se volete alzare
la mano
tanti Come volete Considerate che poco
più di 20 anni fa il de l'email
annunciava La morte di internet poco più
di 20 anni fa si credeva che internet
sarebbe stato qualcosa che non avrebbe
cambiato radicalmente le nostre vite
nel 1970 ci fu il primo inverno
dell'intelligenza artificiale per
inverno si tende un periodo in cui c'è
una forte disillusione su quello che
poteva essere l'impatto degli algoritmi
di intelligenza artificiale sulle nostre
vite e sulle nostre società
porto questi due esempi per mostrarvi
come Nell'era dell'evoluzione
tecnologica si sono ripetuti questi
pattern parte del che hanno sempre la
stessa forma
Garner ha classificato questo tipo di
andamento come gli hype Cycle ovvero
fasi di Forte aspettativa su una
tecnologia come stiamo vivendo di nuovo
Ora sull'intelligenza artificiale
seguite da fase di disillusione in cui
si accorge che l'aspettativa forse era
troppo alta Ma alla fine di questa prima
curva c'è sempre stata una fase di
adozione una fase di adozione che ci ha
portato a dove siamo oggi ovvero in una
continua accelerazione una continua
innovazione con tutti i lati positivi
che si porta a 6 innovazione tecnologica
e anche Ovviamente i lati negativi
Ma come è cambiato il nostro rapporto
con internet Alla fine degli anni 90 ad
oggi magari io c'ero alla fine degli
anni 90 con le prime connessioni con la
linea telefonica dove bisognava occupare
la linea di casa per la felicità dei
parenti che non potevano utilizzare il
telefono con dei pc desktop lenti con un
bel monitor tubo catodico E cosa si
faceva se si collegava e si cercava di
consultare delle pagine web che erano
state pubblicate da qualcuno erano dei
Semplici testi con dei Semplici immagini
e da lì in poi si è visto come c'è stata
un'accelerazione c'è stata
un'accelerazione sia per quanto riguarda
i contenuti che sono diventati sempre
più multimediali grazie anche a un
aumento della banda a disposizione ma se
vediamo cosa è cambiato radicalmente in
questi ultimi anni è il fatto che questi
dispositivi da grandi da PC diciamo da
scrivania sono diventati sempre più
piccoli sempre più performanti sempre
più definiti nel proprio schermo e
soprattutto
interconnessi tra di loro prima vi ho
fatto alzare la mano voi fate parte di
una community di 7 miliardi di persone 7
miliardi di persone che hanno un
dispositivo mobile connesso a internet
equiparati alla popolazione globale
potremmo circa calcolare un 80% di
impatto
quindi capite bene quanto queste queste
tecnologie ci hanno portato sicuramente
ad avere un'evoluzione nella fruizione
dei contenuti in mobilità Ma ha portato
con sé anche sicuramente dei lati
negativi Io sono un tecnologo quindi
sono un fautore stasera mai parlare
sempre in maniera positiva delle
tecnologie però ci sono sicuramente
anche dei lati negativi
statistiche moderne dicono che le nuove
generazioni passano circa 6-7 ore
davanti allo schermo bidimensionale che
guarda caso rispetto al passato è
diventato anche uno schermo
particolarmente piccolo dove bene o male
le nuove generazioni trovano tutto
quello che gli serve trovano il momento
di gioco il momento dell'ingaggio la
socialità la possibilità di comprare la
possibilità di studiare e quant'altro
questo indubbiamente ci sta lontano cioè
si sta allontanando dal contatto con la
terra fisica e sappiamo quanto sia
importante per l'uomo Insomma Sempre
prosperato sulla terra dalla notte dei
tempi ha costruito valori sulla terra
fisica coppia e in questo momento stiamo
deviando Cioè ci stiamo siamo in una
fase in cui ci stiamo Insomma alienati
di fronte a quelli che sono questi
dispositivi che ci portano in una
dimensione quasi totalmente digitale
Ecco Stasera vi parlerò di come oggi ci
troviamo di fronte a una nuova frontiera
che lo crediate o no Ma come avete visto
è in un momento in cui l'uomo si trova
nella comfort zone fa fatica ad
accettare la novità come è stato per
internet non negli anni 2000 Ebbene ci
troviamo di fronte alla nuova frontiera
dove i telefoni delle vostre tasche
scompariranno non ci saranno più
il teorema di fronte è una frontiera in
cui le esperienze cambieranno
radicalmente e voi vi chiederete Ma
com'è possibile che possa continuare a
vivere senza il mio smartphone e senza
la mia notifiche e settare più
applicazioni e bene C'è una tendenza che
anche in questo caso è un ritorno
storico di una tecnologia che si chiama
realtà aumentata la realtà aumentata che
da un decennio ha avuto anche la sua
fase di hype di illusione disillusione
adozione bene oggi trova nuova linfa
trova nuova linfa grazie a grossi
investimenti che ci stanno portando
verso una dimensione diversa
Innanzitutto cos'è la realtà aumentata
la realtà aumentata è l'opportunità di
aggiungere elementi olografici nello
spazio ovvero a differenza di un'altra
Vittoria questa è la cosa molto
importante perché spesso si fa
confusione la realtà aumentata mi
permette di vivere normalmente la mia
vita nel mondo fisico sulla terra e di
aggiungere i contenuti digitali possono
essere bidimensionali possono essere
tridi tradizionali interattivi e possono
vivere nel nostro mondo reale Come posso
fruire di questa opportunità la
possibilità di non restare piegato
davanti allo schermo ma di vedere le
informazioni tutto intorno a me bene
fino ad oggi la frizione di questo tipo
di tecnologia avveniva attraverso lo
smartphone stesso quindi bene o male
tornavo appunto da capo utilizzare uno
Smartphone con una telecamera dove la
telecamera mi riproietta la realtà mi
posiziona molti voi avranno sentito
parlare di Pokémon Go che è stato uno
dei primi esempi di successo di un gioco
che è iniziato a introdurre questo tema
io devo andare in un posto specifico
vedo il Pokémon lo catturo Ecco un gioco
che ha fatturato circa 4-5 miliardi di
dollari però questo è stato un primo
esempio del potenziale questa tecnologia
bene le grandi Corporate oggi stanno
investendo sul prossimo step che è un
occhiale trasparente una lente in un
futuro qualcosa sicuramente
miniaturizzato e poco invasivo una lente
perché perché la lente trasparente
qualcosa che bene o male non va invadere
quello che è il mio campo visivo
virtuale ho un visore o uno schermo
davanti agli occhi nel caso dello
smartphone sono piegato e sono
focalizzato e metto a fuoco quello che è
è uno schermo Questa è una grande
opportunità una grande opportunità
perché immaginate di svegliarvi la
mattina e di poter vedere
contestualizzarsi intorno a voi quelli
che sono le informazioni che a voi
servono per esempio io posso
svegliarmi meglio saranno occhiale vado
in soggiorno e magari sul muro è sempre
sullo stesso muro mi appare l'agenda
della mia giornata Magari mi giro La mia
destra vedo passare un leone un leone
che olografico perché mi a me piacciono
i felini di grandi dimensioni magari
tenerne uno reale in casa potrebbe
essere un problema ma nel momento in cui
posso averne uno olografico Comunque
trovo una mia gratificazione per esempio
un leone che si muove coerentemente con
i muri e con le porte di casa mia magari
posso affacciarmi alla finestra che dà
verso il giardino e vedere la
rappresentazione fotorealistica
tridimensionale della fontana di Trevi
pur non essendore possessore Ma di fatto
io ho una proiezione non potrò toccarla
Perché di fatto è una proiezione
tridimensionale potrò valutare dalle
varie soggettive dove È posizionata però
di fatto l'effetto visivo è quello
fotorealistico
Qual è il parallelismo tra il web per
come lo conosciamo oggi è quello che
sarà il futuro del web Ebbene Stanno
nascendo delle piattaforme come
overteriality che ha introdotto il
concetto di terre digitali ovvero il web
nasce come condivisione quando io
pubblico un contenuto sul mio sito che
può essere davide.com o ed ex.com Per
esempio io sto caricando dei contenuti
che intendo condividere con la community
può essere un sito personale può essere
un aggregatore di contenuti
bene allo stesso modo se è stato
introdotto il concetto di terra digitali
ovvero il fatto che io posso andare a
caricare dei contenuti tridimensionali
che sono geolocalizzati in location
specifiche questo mi permette
all'interno di una community di creare
dei contenuti per cui se vado al
Colosseo e io ho deciso di ancorarci dei
contenuti potrai vivere un'esperienza di
carattere Per esempio turistico potrai
vedere a livello architettonico il
Colosseo ricostruito come Rai tempi
potrai vedere dei Gladiatori che
combattono e il punto di vista è il mio
punto di vista quindi io potrei
spostarmi e vedere da ogni angolo questa
azione potrebbe esserci un avata con
l'intelligenza artificiale che per
esempio mi spiega nella mia lingua in
cinese cosa sta venendo e magari mi
guida si sposta mi porta nelle varie vie
di Roma intorno al Colosseo Ecco questa
è l'opportunità l'opportunità quindi di
creare nuove tipologie di contenuti e
nuove tipologie di esperienza però
qualcuno di voi potrebbe chiedersi bello
possiamo combinare un po' tutte queste
tecnologie
ma nel momento in cui non posso essere
fisicamente al Colosseo quale potrebbe
essere la chiusura del cerchio la
chiusura del cerchio potrebbe avvenire
grazie a un'altra tecnica che la realtà
virtuale la realtà virtuale Anche qui ha
vissuto in un trentennio circa anche più
risultati alti e bassi illusione
disillusione adozione Sappiamo benissimo
molti di voi avresti sentito parlare di
Oculus che poi è stato comprata per un
bilion da da Facebook e tempi Oggi meta
e Sappiamo benissimo quanto sono
dispositivi scomodi occlusivi che però
hanno iniziato a introdurre un tema un
tema quello di vivere gli spazi
immaginari Quindi se sono
impossibilitato a muovermi per vari
motivi sono a casa mia Io posso vivere
delle esperienze diciamo remote bene C'è
un Ulteriore step Ulteriore step che se
io ho L'esperienza di realtà aumentata
al Colosseo Come posso andare a creare
il gemello digitale così viene definito
il Digital Twin del Colosseo bene la
risposta è sempre nell'intelligenza
artificiale Ovvero lo stato dell'arte
degli ultimi mesi ci direttamente
attraverso delle foto acquisite dal
proprio smartphone che tutti voi avete
in tasca di acquisire dei fotogrammi e
di poter ricostruire quello che è il
modello tridimensionale del Colosseo ma
non come un disegno non come un cartoon
proprio foto realistico immaginate di
camminare dentro una foto io ho una foto
che praticamente bidimensionale posso
camminarci dentro posso cambiare la
soggettiva all'interno di un film posso
camminare dentro un film bene se io sono
da casa mia vorrei in qualche modo
condividere la mia esperienza turistica
col mio amico che fisicamente al
Colosseo Ebbene avendone Una
riproduzione foto realistica io posso
proiettarmi col mio Avatar presso il
Colosseo cosa ottengo che io il mio
amico a distanza quindi abbattendo le
distanze le barriere possiamo avere due
esperienze analoghe lui è fisicamente lì
vedrà aumentare il mondo io da casa mia
vedrò una ricostruzione occlusiva totale
capite bene come tutte queste tecnologie
soprattutto intelligenza artificiale che
oggi spaventa no perché se c'è tutto la
documentazione sul fatto dei posti di
lavoro che si andrà a sostituire sulla
scrittura sul videomaking sulle immagini
però qui si sta aprendo una grande
opportunità come è stato nel web per
l'inizio degli anni 2000 ovvero Chi ha
saputo cogliere l'occasione di buttarsi
a capofitto e questo è un invito un
invito a creare contenuti idee perché le
esperienze si stanno spostando da un
modello bidimensionale sostanzialmente
ho un modello aumentato e quindi il solo
limite qui è la fantasia e quindi come
dice Alan Clay che è uno dei fondatori
del personal computer per prevedere per
poter prevedere il futuro bisogna
inventarlo Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]